zu radikal zu weit im abseits das sagte
fdp chef jörg merten über teile seiner
eigenen partei warum er später als
andere vor der radikalisierung waren und
was das für die partei im
bundestagswahljahr bedeutet das frage
ich ihn gleich hier in seiner
heimatregion in der nähe von baden-baden
herzlich willkommen zum zdf
sommerinterview
[Musik]
hallo herr einen schönen platz
ausgesucht wie er sind in ihrer
heimatregion man sieht das sieht besser
aus als anderswo momentan in deutschland
sie kompetente region vorbei gegangen
ist auch osten weggezogen wir reden
gleich auch noch mal über die
wetterkatastrophen aber zunächst einmal
ein paar fakten zu ihnen sie sind ko
vorsitzender der afg sie sind auch für
die afg europaabgeordneter sie treten
nicht zur bundestagswahl an
aber sie werden sicherlich wählen haben
sie sich schon entschieden wem sie ihre
erststimme geben bei dieser wahl
erststimme den direktkandidaten afd
sie würden vermutlich an warum ich das
frage denn der mann den sie da wählen
müssen in ihrem wahlkreis tag mag der
hat zum einen einen aufruf
unterschrieben dass sie bitte
zurücktreten sollten und zum anderen ist
er aufgefallen mit einem tweet wenn ich
das noch ergänzen sagt nach dem attentat
von halle wo er gesagt hat ich bin ja
mal gespannt wer das inszeniert hat
können sie so einen mann tatsächlich
wählen also ich werde mir jetzt erst mal
irritiert weil ich bin ja nur anderen
kreisverband erding kandidatin sie in
den dortigen kandidaten würde ich
problemlos in respektive die kandidatin
das weingut habe ich noch gar nicht
mitgekriegt das werde ich mir noch
sorgsamer überlegen kein klares nein wir
leiden auch gleich noch mal über ihn
erinnert hat habe ich bei meiner gute ja
meine meine bedenken das ist länglich
bekannte schwierige stimmen in ihrer
partei gibt es das haben sie auch
thematisiert darüber reden wir gleich
noch mal gerne nochmal im sitzen bitte
[Musik]
haben wir beginnen mit dem thema das
jetzt momentan ganz deutschland bewegt
im westen deutschlands gibt es schon
mehr als 155 tote durch die wetter
katastrophe in bayern ist jetzt auch der
katastrophenfall ausgerufen worden in
sachsen gibt es massive überschwemmungen
wenn sie diese bilder sehen in diesem
ausmaß diese massivität geht ihnen dann
auch die frage durch den kopf ob das die
vorboten eines veränderten klimas sind
also ich sehe zunächst mal unwetter
wetterlage wie man sie im sommer
manchmal hat die ist diesmal besonders
krass ausgefallen das ist mit der
urologischen sogenannte 5 b wetterlagen
eingeklemmte steve zwischenhochs das
stationäre sich dann heraus regnet in
dem fall extrem vollgesogen und dadurch
kommt diese katastrophe zustande
das kann man gesichert sagen das sagen
auch alle meteorologen inwieweit
klimawandel phänomene der diese
geschichte nun verstärkt haben oder
nicht das wissen wir nicht wenn wir
ehrlich um seriös sind wissen wir das
nicht da sind also leute auch herr
kleber von ihrem sender der sagt sofort
das ist der klimawandel frau karin
göring-eckardt sagt das ist der
klimawandel herr laschet sagt das und
viele andere mehr
sie sagen dass nicht das stimmt die afg
steht dafür eine ganz klare haltung da
kann man auch in ihrem wahlprogramm
reingucken das sagen sie auf seite 174
ja erderwärmung ist nicht abzustreiten
aber man muss damit umgehen
wir sollten uns und ich zitiere mal an
die veränderten bedingungen anpassen
sowie es pflanzen und tiere auch tun
an welches tier denkt ihre partei dar
ich denke zunächst mal an uns menschen
aber sie geben sie als beispiel wie
pflanzen und tiere sollten wir uns
anpassen
ein beispiel wo das gut funktioniert
also ich bin kein biologe und habe diese
passage mit verfasst mir geht es darum
dass sich die menschen anpassen und das
tut noch mit hochtechnologie ich nehme
als exemplarisches beispiel immer die
niederlande
die liegen die kosten teilweise unter
dem unternehmen mehr meeres spiel
sie haben schwierigkeiten die haben es
aber immer im griff gehabt weil sie
wissen wie man die man mit wasser umgeht
das ist in dem land so wir müssen uns
darauf einstellen ich halte es für
menschliche hybris so sagen wir steuern
hier das weltklima auf 0,1 0 2
grad genau das ist menschlich meine
begriffe nicht machbar besonderen hatte
hierfür müssen damit umgehen sie sagen
sie haben diese passage nicht
mitgeschrieben
ihre partei macht aber diesen vergleich
mit den tieren da muss man dann glaube
ich auch dazu sagen dass momentan 150
tierarten pro tag sterben und
wahrscheinlich auch aufgrund von
klimatischen veränderungen dass wir
zumindest diskutiert aber sie haben ja
noch zehn wochen zeit bis zur
bundestagswahl um andere von dieser
position zu überzeugen
in den wahlkampf gehen sie als partei
nicht ganz unbelastet denn sie streiten
darüber wie radikal die afg in zukunft
sein sollte haben sie sich schon
persönlich positioniert nach sechs
jahren als parteivorsitzender sagen sie
teile ihrer partei sind zu radikal
geworden wie groß sehen sie ihren
eigenen anteil an dieser radikalisierung
entwicklung
ich habe keinen anteil an die
realisierung entwicklung und ich würde
radikalisierung entwicklung auch in
abrede stellen dass keine entwicklung
sondern wir haben einfach einzelne
akteure die sich an die spielregeln
nicht halten
die nicht auf der basis des
parteiprogramms sind und wenn sie das
nicht sind dann haben sie unserer partei
nichts zu suchen entsprechend handeln
wir dann schlagen wir irgendwie sie mit
diesen einzelnen kandidaten zum teil
umgegangen sind in der vergangenheit
damit gap hat fast mal in 60 sekunden
zusammen wie sie die entwicklung
begleitet haben männerbund aus
machtkalkül 2016 nennt jörn böcker
meuten sein freund und der freund und
helfer schützt und umgarnt lange dessen
radikalste der flügel ist ein integraler
bestandteil unserer partei und das wird
er auch in zukunft immer bleiben
ewigkeitsgarantie und treueschwüre auch
gegenüber dem schutzpatron der radikalen
von alexander gauland distanziere ich
mich ganz gewiss nicht das werde ich das
glaube ich auch niemals in zukunft tun
sollten selbst zündelte auf den flügel
treffen mit wortschöpfungen refugee
hatten oder marokkanische netto nach
fries und bleibt lange loyal selbst bei
rechtsextremen
wir werden auf den gräbern tanzen ich
habe von andreas kalbitz noch nie
irgendetwas ansatzweise extremistisches
gehört
erst 2020 die entscheidende
kursänderungen leuten fordert eine sehr
deutlichen brandmauer nach rechts aus
eine brandmauer gegen die geister die er
rief erneut die radikalen geister die
sind ja schon vor einigen jahren
tatsächlich sichtbar geworden
jochen hake fällt seit 2015 auf mit
rassistischen äußerungen 2017 hat er
seine berüchtigte dresdner rede mit der
erinnerungs politischen wende um 180
grad gehalten
viele wollten ihnen damals rauswerfen
auch einige aus ihrer partei burke ihn
rauswerfen
sie haben damals gesagt ich sehe darin
keine positionen die außerhalb dessen
liegen was wir akzeptieren können heute
fordern sie eine brandmauer gegen rechts
damals nicht warum damals ich habe auch
damals eine brandmauer gefordert ich
habe allerdings also lassen sie mich
zunächst sagen mich überrascht sein
wissen dass sie mit diesen alten
geschichten heute kommen wahrscheinlich
erst 2021 ich habe in das thema
geschweißt nicht wie vielen interviews
dargelegt wie diese entwicklung bei mir
zustande kam warum ich weil ich
integrativ wirken wollte versucht habe
den damaligen flügel in der partei zu
integrieren und die entwicklung ist
damals nicht klar
ich habe die entwicklung dann
durchlaufen ich musste mir das genau
anschauen ich bin keiner der sofort den
start recht ich schaue genau hin
das hat eine gewisse zeit gebraucht und
es gibt gründe dafür warum ich dann ab
2019 nicht mehr dort war ich hatte damit
2018 abgeschlossen
aber der versuch alle zu integrieren
er musste damals gemacht werden und das
ist einfach eine erfahrung die man macht
das braucht eine gewisse zeit der
versuch ist gescheitert weil der flügel
auch die partei übernehmen wollte das
wurde auch gesagt der flügel ist die
partei solche sachen da hab ich gesagt
so hier ist jetzt tatsächlich grund zum
handeln und seitdem wird und das wissen
sie sehr entschlossen gehandelt andere
haben das sehr viel früher erkannt als
sie also sie sind ja auch noch beim
flügel gewesen an denen damit auch
persönlich auf gewährt und sie sind zu
mehreren treffen gefahren
sie haben auch rückendeckung gegeben wir
haben es gerade eben im beitrag gesehen
zum beispiel für andreas kalbitz da
haben andere schon seit zwei jahren
seine gesinnung diskutiert auch in ihrer
partei noch mal die frage warum haben
sie die brandmauer nicht früher gezogen
weil ich erst den informationsstand
haben
musste den ich vom krieg hatte vermögen
sie mir vorwerfen dass ich spreche die
konkret hatte seit herbst 2009 10 und
seitdem wurde konsequent gehandelt
und übrigens erfolgreich gehandelt weil
sie wissen andreas kalbitz und etliche
andere sind nicht mehr mitglied der
partei und das hat wohl erkennbar mit
meinem und dem handeln anderer
bundesvorstandsmitglieder zu tun empört
ja auch viele in der partei ich halte
völlig richtig und auch notwendig andere
haben früher tatsächlich gewarnt dass es
eine gefahr sein könnte wir können ja
mal schauen weil sie sagen zwar
erfolgreich welche folgen das umdenken
oder das späte umdenken für ihre partei
hatte die wahllisten stehen jetzt wenn
wir mal drauf gucken da ist zum beispiel
in sachsen auf dem sicheren listenplatz
5 andreas harlass das ist ein mann den
man gerichtlich bestätigt einer
lupenreinen neonazi nennen darf und der
schrieb nach dem attentat auf die
synagoge in halle
zitat nochmal zur erinnerung der psycho
von halle hat deutsche erschossen
keine semiten ein antisemitischer tweet
ist dieser mann wählbar oder nicht sie
erwarten doch jetzt nicht von mir dass
ich hier eine verteidigung von einzelnen
listenkandidat entschuldigung aber die
liste in sachsen habe ich wohl aus baden
württemberg mit sicherheit nicht
mitgewählt ich hätte herr lass meine
stimme auch nicht gegeben um das
deutlich zu sagen das ist dort so
gewählt worden und das ist dann zu
respektieren er als listenkandidat meine
stimme hat er nicht bekommen es gibt
weitere sie können das wir können die 20
minuten damit verbringen dass
einzelpersonen durch zu deckeln jens
maier listenplatz aber jetzt
direktkandidat in sachsen da möchte
gerne herrn kallwitz über dessen
rauswurf sie sich freuen wieder zurück
in die einfachere suchen
und er sagt wer in diesen zeiten nicht
als rechtsextremist diffamiert wird
macht irgendwas verkehrt empfehlen sie
denn ganz meyer zu wählen weil ich finde
dass er mit solchen sprüchen etwas
verkehrt macht und das habe ich auch
sehr deutlich
ich habe herrn meier ja nicht auf der
liste gewählt
wir können die 20 minuten in toto damit
verbringe ich wüsste noch zehn zwölf
namen zu sagen die man in vielen
vernünftigen guten leuten die wir haben
gegen wwk die wirklich äußerungen machen
die grenze ist noch lang also wir hätten
zum beispiel anti terror ich nicht ich
würde gerne gucken wie sie mit einem
aktuellen fall umgehen der ist ganz neu
damit beschäftigen sie sich auch gerade
matthias helferich stellvertretender
landes
in nordrhein westfalen listenplatz
nummer 7 er bezeichnet sich selbst in
internen chat als das freundliche
gesicht des ns die abkürzung steht für
nationalsozialismus wählbar oder nicht
sie schicken diese leute in den
bundestag wir werden uns diese causa
helferich sehr genau anschauen werden
das jetzt am freitag in die präsenz
sitzung des bundesvorstandes eingeplant
die konnte nicht stattfinden ich musste
selber mit dem auto erklärt nachdem
wegen der unwetter katastrophe
wir haben herrn helferich am kommenden
freitag im bundesvorstand vorgeladen und
dann werden wir genau diese äußerung
überprüfen
es besteht nicht der geringste zweifel
daran dass das äußerungen sind die
unsere partei ganz und gar nicht gehen
aber die rechtstaatlichkeit gebietet es
jeden anzuhören das werden wir am
kommenden freitag tun
wir machen nicht ewig weiter aber da sie
jetzt bisher keinen dieser kandidaten
unterstützt haben wir haben noch andere
namen christina die maden die und stefan
brandner jürgen pohl können sie einen
der drei empfehlen für den bundestag
also da alles nicht meine freunde und
sie wissen es und sie empfehlen sie auch
nicht ich habe keine empfehlungen
auszusprechen dass entscheidung der
wähler ich habe das verstanden sie
können tatsächlich nicht alle kfd
kandidaten empfehlen vielleicht ja auch
weil einige dieser leute mehr stellen
radikal 100 diese leute sind mit
radikalen forderungen unterwegs und
parolen die sie auch nicht unterstützen
beispiel corona politik da haben sie
ganz klar vor einem radikalen kurs
gewarnt vor der wahl in sachsen-anhalt
haben sie gesagt macht das nicht zu
krass sinngemäß hören wir uns das mal an
was sie genau gesagt haben und welche
reaktion später darauf haben wir leben
in keiner diktatur sonst könnten wir
diesen parteitag heute wohl nachkommen
so abhalten
ich jedenfalls werde auch künftig die
korona diktator als corona diktatur
bezeichnet
ich habe für euch hiermit auf
verschwörungstheorien sie schmunzelnd
erneuten wenn man das hört weil das
immer gleiche muster
es ist das immer ganz bewusst hat man es
ist ja auch von ihrer partei häufiger
vor und dann wird's ja ein muster wenn
man das hört wie viel gewicht hat ihre
stimme dann auch in der korona politik
ich glaube dass meine stimme deutlich
höheres gewicht hat als die fanghand
hielt schneider den
einspielen aber auch die parteispitze
hat sie darauf laufen lassen sie haben
nach der wahl in sachsen anhalt noch
einmal gesagt der kasse protest kurs in
diesem von corona geprägten wahlkampf
das war keine gute sache dazu hat herr
gauland gesagt das sei dummes zeug und
tino copala ihr ko-vorsitzender hat
gesagt das sei eine einzelne
einzelstimme eines parteimitglieds sache
in corona fragen ist herr kubala der
vorsitzende und sie sind nur irgendein
mitglied nein also erstmal der
arithmetische recht ist das eine stimmen
sowie seine stimme eine stimme ist das
ist für mich auch in ordnung
es muss dazu jeder seine eigene position
haben und ich erlaube mir immer und
ausnahmslos beim so ernsten thema weko
wird alle mal den luxus einer
differenzierten haltung und in der kurve
politik der bundesregierung ist vieles
katastrophal schief gelaufen
auch auf eu ebene das müssen wir
kritisieren das müssen wir laut
kritisieren gleichzeitig sollten wir
nicht in eine völlige antihaltung gehen
und ich mache mal exemplarisch klar an
mir selbst und meine familie
ich selbst bin geimpft diebinnen bin
durchgeben entscheidung habe ich für
mich getroffen ich kritisiere niemanden
der sich nicht impfen lässt um meine
kinder zum beispiel würde ich ganz
sicherlich nicht gegen grippe impfen
lassen weil hier die
gefahren deutlich höher sind als der
nutzen daraus erwächst man muss sich die
frage ist ja wer setzt sich dann am ende
durch ihre stimme oder die derjenigen
die etwas radikaleres wollen in der
europapolitik in der europapolitik haben
sie sich zumindest im wahlprogramm auch
nicht durchgesetzt
da wollten sie keinesfalls den so
genannten text den austritt deutschlands
aus der europäischen union jetzt steht
er leicht verbrennt doch drin warum
konnten sie sich da nicht durchsetzen es
hat sich auf diesem bundesparteitag in
dresden zugetragen dass zwei
verschiedene richtungen er verteile sich
da verbrüdert haben zu dieser decke
position zwar zum einen die
nationalkonservativen nicht nennen sie
amazon zum anderen die libertäre
ausgerichteten moment böhringer und
überwältigen das sorgte dann dafür dass
mit diesen beiden gruppierungen
diese position reinkam die ist so
respektieren dass ein
parteitagsbeschluss ich habe offen
gesagt ich habe das ein anderes gesagt
ich halte das für ein fehler
ich zahle die zeche dafür jeden tag in
brüssel wir können wenn wir in brüssel
etwas erreichen wollen und große teile
unserer politik werden von den bürgern
völlig unbemerkt heute in brüssel
gemacht und nicht in berlin
wenn wir dort etwas erreichen wollen
dann werden wir das nicht als einzige
reaktion schaffen dann muss ich mit
anderen delegationen dort kooperieren
mit denen habe ich nur ein riesenproblem
weil dir sagen eure dexxit forderung die
passt überhaupt nicht in unser in
unserer richter sie haben einen
langjährigen weggefährten darüber
verloren last patrick berg ist deswegen
aus der afc ausgetreten und da sagt
dieser beschluss war gefährlich er hat
das sehr konsequent gehandelt sie
vertreten jetzt etwas wohinter sie
eigentlich nicht stehen stört sie das
nicht dass sie das jetzt verkaufen
müssen
ich muss das nicht verkaufen weil ich
ihn ja hier auch klar sage ich halte
diesen beschluss für einen fehler
ich kann nicht aber die sicher
schlusslichts ihnen kann mich ich kann
mich aber nicht gegen einen
parteitagsbeschluss erstellen das ist
eine mehrheitsentscheidung das habe ich
auch als vorsitzender zu respektieren
die lust ist gerade aus dass sie müssen
auch mittragen was ihr co vorsitzender
timo grub aller außenpolitisch so von
sich gibt er ist gerade in moskau
gewesen hat da eine viel beachtete rede
gehalten die auch aus ihrer partei stark
kritisiert worden ist als anbieter
wiederum an wladimir putin joachim
steinhöfel den mann kennen sie gut ist
anwalt vertritt die afg hat dazu
geschrieben sein
war widerlich ahnungslos beschämend und
genuin dumm hat der mann recht
ich kenne diese formulierung von joachim
steinhöfel steinhöfel nike zu plakativen
formulierung ich denke das kind in der
wortwahl finde ich das eindeutig zu
krass ich bin allerdings mit ihm der
meinung dass diese reise von tino copala
die rede auf einladung des russischen
verteidigungsministers und auch der
inhalt der rede ich würde vom
vorsichtiger formulieren unglück war
also ich würde mich würden wir nicht die
adjektive von den steinen wird so eigen
machen ich halte davon aber wenig es ist
ein fehler der sich auch häufiger
wiederholt und ich glaube auch dass das
in wahlkampfzeiten relativ wenig sehen
hat auch frau war eine woche vor der
landtagswahl komplett in russland vor
der baden württembergischen landtagswahl
habe ich auch für nicht klug gehalten
hat sie gemacht muss jeder für sich
selber wissen darf versuchen sie sich
jetzt dagegen zu stemmen fassen wir das
mal zusammen nach sechs jahren
parteivorsitz übrigens keine anderer
länger an auf dieser position heraus
gehalten sie müssen sie massiv gegen
teile der partei und ihre parteispitze
kämpfen
das erinnert an eine ehemalige
fdp-vorsitzende nämlich frauke petry die
hat ihnen gerade noch eine neue
korruptionsermittlungen beschert in dem
sie gesagt hat sie hätten sie erbeuten
hätten illegale spendengelder in die
partei hinein gelenkt und den
offiziellen strukturen vorbei eingesetzt
haben sie das getan
nein habe ich nicht getan die aussage
ist falsch ihr solltet ihr ehrung sie
hatten sie hat informationen darüber
ja natürlich können ihren vorgeben ich
habe keine gelder angenommen und illegal
in die partei hinein kling ich hab's
nicht mal als legal getan
sie können auch versichern dass da nicht
noch weitere ungeklärte spenden fälle in
ihrem bereich auftauchen in meinem für
meinen bereich kann ich das definitiv
versichern aber lassen sie mich sagen
ich habe da ich habe da wegen dieser
äußerung staatsanwaltschaftliche
ermittlungen da wird die immunität
aufgehoben wofür ich gar nicht undankbar
bin damit das endlich mal geklärt wird
ich kann darüber nicht frankfurt frei
reden die würde das sogar relativ gerne
um diesen unfug auszuräumen
ich kann das
sechs jahre parteivorsitz wir haben auch
gerade gesagt lange zeit wann geben sie
diese position ab dieses amt das wird
sich zeigen also frau petri hat das dann
jahr 2017 gemacht halo hat das gemacht
und hingeworfen hinwerfen ist nicht
meine art das mache ich nicht
es gibt hier sind diesen schönen
englischen spricht kern street day of
kitchen wenn du die hitze nicht
aushalten kann es dann raus aus der
küche das ist eine ziemliche küche ich
kann das aushalten und ich weiß dass
sehr viele wünschen dass ich das tun und
die zu enttäuschend fiel mir sehr schwer
hermann vielen dank für das gespräch
sehr gern das war das zdf
sommerinterview mit dem co vorsitzenden
der afd in der kommenden woche trifft
theo koll den parteivorsitzenden der cdu
und kanzlerkandidaten armin laschet
vielen dank fürs zuschauen schönen abend
[Musik]